Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture
générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne
commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à
mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous
dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder
la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
Qu’est-ce que la France ?
D’après le juriste néerlandais
Hugo Grotius, qui a écrit ses œuvres
majeures en exil en France, ce pays est «
le plus beau royaume après celui du Ciel ».
Moi qui ai quitté l’hexagone il y a 6 ans,
je reste encore sensible à son charme.
Je me rends compte que la France,
c’est aussi un art de vivre et un rapport
au monde qui n’ont, d’après mon expérience,
pas d’équivalent à l’étranger. Je constate
aussi combien elle est une nation particulière,
avec une identité forte, aux yeux des étrangers.
Mais comment la définir ? C’est un sujet
controversé, parce que l’identité nationale est un
cadre qui légitime certaines options politiques,
et en disqualifie d’autres. Les
choix des décideurs doivent être
cohérents avec leur vision de la France.
Je vais donc essayer — à mon modeste niveau — de
m’en tenir à ce qui fait consensus.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux
questions suivantes :
* Quelles sont les
caractéristiques du territoire français ?
* Quelles sont les caractéristiques de la
population française ?
* Quelles sont les
particularités de la langue française ?
* Comment décrire la culture française ?
* En quoi le fonctionnement
du pays est-il particulier ?
Quelles sont les caractéristiques
du territoire français ?
« L’espace français est une richesse,
et donc un devoir », a dit Edgard Pisani,
ministre de l’Agriculture dans les années 1960.
Quelles en sont les
caractéristiques géographiques ?
On distingue 3 ensembles géographiques :
1. la France métropolitaine, les 96 départements
situés en Europe de l’ouest ;
2. les 5 départements
d'Outre-mer (DOM) :
* la Guadeloupe (groupe d'îles
dans le sud de la mer des Caraïbes) ;
* la Guyane (région sur la côte
nord-est de l'Amérique du Sud) ;
* la Réunion (île de de l'océan
Indien, au sud-est de l’Afrique) ;
* la Martinique (une île des Caraïbes
près de la Guadeloupe) ;
* Mayotte (un archipel de
l'océan Indien au nord de Madagascar) ;
3. les autres collectivités : Nouvelle-Calédonie,
Polynésie française, îles Wallis et Futuna,
Terres australes et antarctiques françaises,
îles éparses de l'Océan indien ainsi que
la collectivité territoriale à statut
particulier de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon.
La France métropolitaine a une superficie
de 550 000 km2, ce qui fait d’elle le 41e plus
grand pays du monde (dont elle représente 0,45
% de la surface) ; le 3e d’Europe (après la Russie
et l’Ukraine) ; et le 1er de l’Union européenne.
Elle a des frontières terrestres avec
6 pays : la Belgique, le Luxembourg,
l'Allemagne, la Suisse, l'Italie, l'Espagne ;
et avec 2 principautés : Andorre et Monaco.
Quelles sont les caractéristiques
environnementales et climatiques ?
Les paysages de la France métropolitaine sont très
variés : plaines agricoles, forêts, montagnes,
littoraux de diverses natures, vallées. La
biodiversité est grande, et la cohabitation de la
ville et de la nature est plutôt harmonieuse.
Concernant l’eau, vous pouvez retenir
que la France métropolitaine :
* est bordée par l’océan Atlantique à l’ouest ;
* est bordée par la mer du Nord au
nord, par la Manche au nord-nord-ouest,
et par la mer Méditerranée au sud-est ;
* est traversée par 4 grands fleuves : la
Loire, la Seine, la Garonne et le Rhône ;
* est aussi traversée par la Meuse et le Rhin,
qui sont importants en Europe.
Les montagnes occupent près de 30
% du territoire. On dénombre 6 massifs : les
Alpes (sud-est), les Pyrénées (sud-ouest),
le Jura (centre-est), le Massif central
(sud-centre), les Vosges (nord-est), et les
massifs de la Corse (une île méditerranéenne).
Les forêts couvrent elles aussi 30 % du territoire
métropolitain (proportion qui augmente depuis le
début du XIXe siècle), ce qui représente 10 % de
la surface boisée européenne. Elles sont
aux trois quarts des propriétés privées.
Le climat de la France métropolitaine
est varié en raison de la superficie et
de la position du territoire. Comme
pour la majeure partie de l’Europe,
il est dans l’ensemble tempéré, c’est-à-dire
que les températures n’y sont pas extrêmes.
On peut également préciser que :
* le climat est océanique à l’ouest,
ce qui produit des hivers doux et humides et des
étés plus frais (particulièrement en Bretagne,
même si les Bretons disent « qu’il
ne pleut que sur les cons ») ;
* le climat est continental dans la majeure
partie du territoire, où l’écart de température
entre les saisons est plus important ;
* le climat est méditerranéen dans le sud-est,
ce qui produit des étés chauds et
secs et des hivers doux et humides.
Enfin, la France a la réputation d’un
pays respectueux de l’environnement.
Divers paramètres ne cessent cependant de
se dégrader : les eaux sont polluées par
les déchets solides et par les pesticides ;
la justice européenne a condamné l’État pour
la pollution de l’air ; les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre baissent, mais la température
augmente ; la qualité des sols se dégrade ; et
enfin, la biodiversité continue de s’éroder.
Quelles sont les caractéristiques
de la population française ?
Combien sommes-nous ?
Selon l’INSEE,
la France compte 67 millions d’habitants en 2020,
dont 65 millions en métropole et 2 millions dans
les 5 départements d’outre-mer. Cela représente
environ ⅙ de la population de l’Union européenne.
Depuis les années 2000, la population augmente de
0,3 à 0,5 % par an, c’est-à-dire qu’elle accueille
entre 150 et 200 000 nouvelles personnes.
Le solde naturel (la différence entre les
naissances et les décès) explique les trois
quarts de la hausse ; le solde migratoire (la
différence entre les entrées et les sorties
du territoire) explique le dernier quart.
Voici quelques précisions intéressantes :
* il y a presque 52 % de femmes ;
* plus d’un Français sur six a moins de 15
ans, et plus d’un sur cinq a plus de 65 ans ;
* il y a 10 % d’immigrés (personnes nées
étrangères à l’étranger), dont presque la moitié
sont nés en Afrique et le tiers en Europe ;
* l’espérance de vie est de 85,5 ans pour
les femmes, 80 ans pour les hommes ;
* la fécondité est de 1,9 enfants par femme ;
* nous serons plus de 75
millions en 2060 (selon l’Ined).
Où vivons-nous ?
Pour l’INSEE, « une unité urbaine est une
commune ou un ensemble de communes qui comporte
sur son territoire une zone bâtie d'au moins 2 000
habitants où aucune habitation n'est séparée
de la plus proche de plus de 200 mètres ».
La population française est à 80 % urbaine. La
région la plus urbaine est l’Île-de-France ; la
moins urbaine est la Franche-Comté (centre-est),
composé de nombreuses petites communes. La part de
la population urbaine augmente progressivement.
Elle est concentrée dans les plus grandes villes.
1 personne sur 2 vit dans une unité urbaine
de plus de 100 000 habitants, 1 sur 4 dans une
unité urbaine de plus de 200 000 habitants (hors
celle de Paris). Enfin, l’agglomération parisienne
regroupe à elle seule presque 11 millions
d’habitants, soit ⅙ de la population française.
Voici les populations (intra-muros)
des 10 plus grandes villes :
1. Paris (2,2 millions) ;
2. Marseille (870 000) ;
3. Lyon (520 000) ;
4. Toulouse (490 000) ;
5. Nice (340 000) ;
6. Nantes (320 000) ;
7. Montpellier (290 000) ;
8. Strasbourg (285 000) ;
9. Bordeaux (260 000) ;
10. Lille (235 000).
Comment vivons-nous ?
La France compte environ
30 millions de ménages, c’est-à-dire de
groupes d’occupants (pas nécessairement de
la même famille) d’un même logement.
La taille des ménages continue de se
réduire : plus d’un tiers sont constitués d’une
seule personne (le plus souvent des seniors) ; un
tiers de deux personnes ; et à peine un tiers de
trois personnes ou plus. Parmi la population âgée
de plus de 15 ans, 1 personne sur 5 vit seule à
la fin des années 2010, contre 1 sur 6 en 1990.
Le modèle du couple parental marié recule :
* environ 45 % des mariages finissent en
divorce ;
* presque
un quart des familles sont monoparentales
(contre 12 % en 1990), et il y a autant de
familles ayant à leur tête un couple non marié ;
* près de 8 % des familles sont recomposées ;
* presque 1 famille sur 2 a un seul enfant, et
1 sur 6 est une famille « nombreuse » au sens
de l’administration (plus de 3 enfants).
Concernant l’éclatement des communautés,
on peut également noter que la France est le pays
d'Europe de l'Ouest où l'on se suicide le plus,
et que la possession d’un animal de compagnie
reste au même niveau (1 Français sur 2) depuis
les années 1980 malgré l’urbanisation (l’animal
devient inutile et plus contraignant à la ville).
Quelles sont les particularités
de la langue française ?
« La France, a dit Napoléon, c’est le
français quand il est bien écrit ».
Quelle est l’origine de notre langue ?
Le français vient du latin vulgaire
(ou « populaire »), c’est-à-dire des dialectes qui
se sont formés en s’éloignant progressivement du
latin classique dans l’Empire romain. Cette langue
d’origine a 2 caractéristiques intéressantes : 1°
elle donne une large place aux métaphores, et 2°
elle simplifie le système de formation des mots.
Les linguistes classent donc le français parmi
les langues romanes, lesquelles appartiennent
à la famille des langues indo-européennes.
On dit traditionnellement que les Serments
de Strasbourg (842), une alliance militaire
conclue entre deux frères contre un troisième,
sont « l’acte de naissance » de la langue
française. Alors que les documents officiels
étaient à l’époque rédigés en latin, les alliés
ont prononcé les serments dans les langues
parlées par leurs soldats, le roman, ancêtre du
français, et le tudesque, ancêtre de l’allemand.
Le roman devient le français vers le XIIe siècle.
Comment la langue française évolue-t-elle ?
« Les langues, explique le philosophe
écossais David Hume, sont graduellement
établies par des conventions humaines
» (Traité de la nature humaine).
Sur la longue durée, une langue est un ordre
spontané : elle n’est pas un système fixe ; bien
au contraire, elle mute en permanence en
fonction de l’usage et de l’évolution de la
société. D’innombrables mots et combinaisons
de mots apparaissent, se transforment,
ou disparaissent. Le français, par exemple,
a notamment été influencé par le latin,
le grec ancien, l'italien et l'anglais — et
il a lui-même influencé d’autres langues.
On distingue 4 versions de la langue française :
1. l’ancien français (du IXe au XIIIe siècle),
qui a laissé des traces en anglais ;
2. le moyen français (XIVe et XVe siècles),
où a disparu la déclinaison (ouf) ;
3. le français classique (du XVIe au XVIIIe
siècle), qui a servi de base à la grammaire ;
4. le français moderne (à partir du XVIIIe
siècle), qui sera progressivement adopté
par la totalité de la population.
À notre époque, le français évolue principalement
par l’influence de la culture américaine. Comme
dans d’autres pays, le gouvernement essaie de
protéger la langue nationale des influences
étrangères. La loi Toubon de 1994 a par exemple
rendu le français obligatoire dans un certain
nombre de communications, notamment dans les
services publics. On peut également relever
l’influence (intentionnelle) du féminisme, même
si l’Académie française défend la tradition
contre cette influence.
Où parle-ton français ?
La diffusion du français en France a été un enjeu
politique. En 1539, la fameuse ordonnance de
Villers-Cotterêts en fait la langue exclusive
de l’administration (à la place du latin et
des dialectes) par souci d’efficacité et
pour renforcer la monarchie. En 1794, le
rapport Grégoire révèle qu’à peine 1 Français
sur 5 parle la langue de l’administration.
Mais « on peut uniformer le langage d’une
grande nation… », suggère l’auteur. Le
pouvoir révolutionnaire impose alors le français
comme langue maternelle à tous les citoyens.
Le français a donc d’abord été la
langue de l’élite, même internationale,
avant de devenir celle du peuple français.
Aux XVIIe et XVIIIe siècles, il est « le
point de communication de tous les peuples de
l'Europe », comme l’écrit le philosophe français
Pierre Bayle. Il est la langue véhiculaire
qui sert à toutes les cours européennes.
Aujourd’hui, environ 300 millions
de personnes, sur les 5 continents,
parlent le français. C’est une des langues
étrangères les plus enseignées dans le monde,
et une des langues les plus utilisées sur
internet (sa place varie selon les classements).
Comment décrire la culture française ?
« Le vin est senti par la nation française
comme un bien qui lui est propre, au même
titre que ses trois cent soixante espèces
de fromage et sa culture », écrit le philosophe
français Roland Barthes dans ses Mythologies.
Qu’est-ce que la « culture » ? Je
la définis comme l’ensemble des
productions de l’esprit et des valeurs d’un
groupe humain — en l’occurrence la France.
Quelles sont les productions
de « l’esprit français » ?
Tout d’abord, cet esprit a
produit des idées influentes :
* le philosophe Montaigne (qui a été maire de
Bordeaux), une référence de l’humanisme de la
Renaissance, a inspiré avec ses Essais les plus
grands auteurs européens des siècles suivants ;
* au XVIIe siècle, le mathématicien et philosophe
Descartes (qui vivait aux Pays-Bas) a carrément
fondé, avec son fameux Discours de la
méthode, l’esprit de la science moderne,
mais aussi de la philosophie moderne ;
* les philosophes francophones des
Lumières (notamment Rousseau [qui
est suisse], Voltaire, Diderot,
et Montesquieu) et les penseurs de la Révolution
française ont promu les libertés individuelles
et l’égalité politique dans le monde entier ;
* les sociologues français (notamment Alexis
de Tocqueville, Auguste Comte, Émile
Durkheim, ou encore Pierre Bourdieu)
sont des références de la discipline ;
* dans la seconde moitié du XXe siècle,
la philosophie de Jean-Paul Sartre
a nourri la libération des mœurs
et stimulé la décolonisation ;
* la French Theory, c’est-à-dire
les idées postmodernes françaises, est à
l’origine du « gauchisme » contemporain qui
inspire les nouveaux mouvements de lutte
contre les discriminations (féminisme,
antiracisme, défense des minorités sexuelles).
Les idées françaises semblent aujourd’hui moins
influentes, mais certains intellectuels
tirent leur épingle du jeu. Par exemple,
Thomas Piketty est devenu « la rock-star de
l’économie » (selon le Financial Times) grâce au
succès de son livre Le Capital au XXIe siècle.
Mais le patrimoine culturel français,
ce sont aussi :
* une littérature
très riche mondialement admirée (la France est le
pays le plus gâté par le Nobel de littérature) ;
* un grand nombre de peintres et de
sculpteurs qui sont mis à l’honneur
dans des musées dans le monde entier ;
* une architecture reconnue et influente,
des châteaux à l’urbanisme moderne ;
* la chanson française, très influente
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale ;
* le luxe de la mode parisienne et
des stations balnéaires du sud ;
* la diversité de la gastronomie
et l’excellence des chefs cuisiniers.
Quelles sont les traits culturels qui
caractérisent les Français ?
Pour répondre à cette question,
je vais m’intéresser aux clichés les
plus courants, parce qu’ils révèlent
comment les étrangers nous perçoivent.
Tout d’abord, on peut dire que la nourriture
occupe une place importante dans la vie des
Français. Ils aiment la bonne cuisine et
les bons restaurants ; ils ne commencent pas un
repas sans leur baguette ; ils aiment le fromage,
le vin rouge, et des aliments « spéciaux » comme
les escargots ou les cuisses de grenouilles
(c’est d’ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
les Anglais nous appellent « frogs » !).
Les Français passent plus généralement pour
des gens raffinés et curieux. Intellectuels,
ils aiment la littérature, la philosophie, les
arts et les débats interminables pour refaire
le monde. Amatrices de haute-couture, les
femmes incarnent une élégance distinguée. Le
mythe du French lover dit que les hommes
sont charmants, poétiques, efféminés,
sexuellement compétents, mais… infidèles !
Mais les Français sont en même temps grossiers.
Les sondages révèlent qu’ils ont la plus
mauvaise réputation au monde. Arrogants,
ils ne prennent pas la peine d’apprendre les
langues étrangères et ne sont pas accueillants,
au point que les touristes — japonais, pour
la plupart — développent le « syndrome de
Paris ». Ils seraient malpolis au point
que les anglophones disent « Pardon my
French » lorsqu’ils sont vulgaires. Ils seraient
encore sales (!), au point qu’ils se contentent
d’un coup de parfum bas de gamme pour couvrir
les mauvaises odeurs (c’est la French shower).
Sur le plan politique, enfin, le peuple
français se distingue par la résistance à
l’autorité. Auteur de la plus grande révolution
de l’histoire, son esprit d’insubordination,
manifeste dans les grèves et les manifestations,
continue à étonner les pays étrangers.
Les Français passent également pour des
fainéants. « La vie n’est pas simplement une
petite annexe du travail », avait dit le président
Mitterrand pour défendre la semaine de 35 heures.
En quoi le fonctionnement du
pays est-il particulier ?
« Sans le Gouvernement, on ne rirait plus
en France », a écrit le moraliste Chamfort.
En quoi le système politique
français est-il particulier ?
La France est une république, c’est-à-dire qu’elle
se définit par opposition à la monarchie. Le
pouvoir n’est pas héréditaire ; il est partagé et
exercé dans l’intérêt général. Une constitution
encadre le fonctionnement du système politique.
Depuis 1958, le régime politique en vigueur est
la Ve République. Celle-ci se distingue des
précédentes par le rôle central qu’elle accorde
au président, que le professeur de droit
Maurice Duverger qualifiait de « monarque
républicain ». « Un des caractères essentiels
de la Constitution de la Ve République,
a expliqué le président Charles de Gaulle en
1962, c’est qu’elle donne une tête à l’État. »
Le premier article de la Constitution précise
les valeurs fondamentales de ce régime : « la
France est une République indivisible,
laïque, démocratique et sociale ».
La France est aussi une démocratie. Le
pouvoir émane donc du peuple, qui l’attribue
à intervalles réguliers, à l'occasion
d'élections libres et disputées. De surcroît,
la démocratie française est moderne parce qu’elle
garantit la liberté et les droits de l’homme.
En quoi l’État français
caractérise-t-il la France ?
« Il n’y a de France que grâce
à l’État », déclarait le général de Gaulle
en 1960, alors en pleine crise algérienne.
L’État français a un poids exceptionnel dans
la vie du pays. Cette spécificité est née après
la Révolution française. En effet, celle-ci a
défait l’organisation sociale de l’Ancien régime,
où l’écrivain Mirabeau ne voyait qu’« un agrégat
de peuples désunis ». L’institution étatique a
alors réorganisé, uniformisé, et unifié
la nation française autour de sa figure,
qui incarne l’intérêt général. L’historien Pierre
Rosanvallon dit qu’elle a « produit la nation ».
Aujourd’hui, l’État intervient
largement dans l’économie et la
société pour assurer des prestations aux
citoyens : il est un « État-providence ».
La fonction publique est ainsi très développée.
En 2020, elle comptait 5,5 millions d’agents
(fonctionnaires ou contractuels), soit 20 % de
l’emploi total et 82 fonctionnaires pour 1000
habitants (contre 60 en moyenne en Europe)
— ce qui en fait la 6e fonction publique la
plus développée dans l’OCDE (derrières les
pays scandinaves, notamment). D’un côté,
les citoyens jouissent de services publics
étendus et fiables ; mais de l’autre,
la bureaucratie pénalise l’activité du pays
(certains parlent d’un « impôt formulaire »).
En quoi l’économie française
est-elle particulière ?
La France est tout d’abord un pays riche. En 2020,
elle est la 6e puissance économique mondiale et
la 2e puissance économique européenne derrière
l'Allemagne. Cependant, ses entreprises sont
de moins en moins compétitives ; les chômeurs
sont de plus en plus nombreux (environ 9 % de la
population active) ; et la dette publique grossit
année après année (presque 120 % du PIB en 2020).
L’économie française se distingue aussi par le
poids de la fiscalité. Les journalistes disent
volontiers que la France est « championne du monde
de la pression fiscale ». La fiscalité française
est également particulièrement complexe :
on dénombrait en 2019 plus de 250 impôts
et taxes différents… Toutefois, par l’effet de la
redistribution, les inégalités de revenu sont plus
faibles que dans la plupart des pays européens.
« La France est un pays extrêmement fertile,
a dit le président Clémenceau : on y
plante des fonctionnaires et il y pousse
des impôts ».
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.